also breaking club 2100 is now shut down
after a unanimous vote by city council
members club 2100 on east fremont known
for a history of violent crimes earlier
this year a man was shot and killed
outside of the club council members and
mayor carolyn goodman want to make it
clear they are taking a stand against
violence she addressed the owner
francisco lara directly
i just i i can't have it i just this is
our city
every day is a new day for everybody
that's made a mistake to do their part
to keep us safe law enforcement works
fire and rescue work all the time
selflessly every morning and they don't
know if they're coming home and you're
operating a business for nine years like
this it is beyond appalling i don't know
how you get up in the mirror and look at
yourself
the club's business license liquor
license tobacco licenses and an atm
license all revoked the owner's attorney
tried to argue his client made changes
to make the club safer but metro has
described this place as a quote
comfortable place for gang members to
meet